كما لاحظت للتو، نحن الآن في
السنة الثانية من هذه الحرب،
وعلى الرغم من مدى الكارثة التي حلت
بالجانب الروسي، إلا أنه لا يبدو أنه
يغير مساره، ولا يبدو أنه
ينسحب أو يستمتع بأي نوع من
المفاوضات.  لقد قام مدير وكالة المخابرات المركزية
بيل بيرنز بتقييم
عقلية فلاديمير بوتين في وقت سابق اليوم على شبكة سي بي إس
نيوز، وإليك القليل مما كان عليه
أن يقوله.
أعتقد أن بوتين واثق تمامًا الآن
من قدرته على إنهاك
أوكرانيا بحيث لا يمكن سحقها، وهذا  ما
يقدمه هو كل الأدلة على أنه
عازم على القيام به الآن، وفي مرحلة ما،
سيتعين عليه مواجهة
التكاليف المتزايدة وكذلك في التوابيت التي
تعود إلى موطنها في بعض أفقر المناطق
في روسيا، هناك ضرر اقتصادي تراكمي
لروسيا بالإضافة إلى
سمعة ضخمة  لم يكن الضرر
إعلانًا رائعًا لمبيعات الأسلحة الروسية،
لذا سيتزايد هذا بمرور
الوقت، لكن الإجابة الصادقة الآن هي أن
بوتين مصمم تمامًا
وجيم فيما يتعلق بالضرر الاقتصادي، فقد
أعلن الاتحاد الأوروبي للتو عن
جولته العاشرة من العقوبات.  ضد
العقوبات الروسية التي وصفها الرئيس زيلينسكي
بأنها قوية